public sénat en partenariat avec afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir pierre moscovici et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec les échos avec radio
classique et avec l afp vous répondrai
au cours de cette émission à trois
grandes questions dans un instant
jean-francis pécresse viendra vous
demander si la france va bel et bien
passée selon bout sous la fameuse barre
des 3% de déficit alors que le
gouvernement il a dit aujourd'hui compte
sur la surtaxe sur les entreprises
deuxième question lucile malandain vous
demandera si emmanuel macron un quart
d'un nouveau leadership pour l'europe
enfin mickaël szames s vous interrogera
sur l'avancée du populisme en europe
dans de nombreux pays
comment lui faire barrage mais d'abord
une toute première question d'actualité
[Musique]
on parlait du populisme à l'instant le
nationalisme est un avatar du populisme
pour certains que vous inspirez pierre
moscovici les derniers épisodes de la
crise catalan avec le mandat d'arrêt est
requis par un procureur espagnol à
l'encontre de carless plus de monde qui
est toujours réfugié en belgique on
commente pas les décisions de justice
dans son pays où les commandes pas dans
d'autres pays non plus chaque système à
son système d'état de droit il faut le
respecter
plus généralement ce que m'inspire la
sphère catalogue catalan s'est d'abord
que c'est un problème espagnole avant
tout qui doit être résolu par les
espagnols dans le cadre de l'état de
droit espagnol de l'ordre
constitutionnel espagnol et de ceux
conduits là il n'y a pas beaucoup de
doutes sur le fait que d'une part
l'espagne est un état qui est le seul
que l'union européenne connaissent un
état de droit nous allons mais quand
vous entendez certains qui sont là il ya
des relents du franquisme aujourd'hui je
vais y venir
deuxièmement que le référendum qui a été
convoqué à l'époque n'est pas un
référendum légale au sens de la
constitution espagnole ensuite à
l'évidence la violence n'est pas la
solution il faudra trouver les voies du
dialogue et de la démocratie de ce point
de vue là ce seront les prochaines
élections
enfin convoqué en décembre d'internés
sand qui seront le juge de paix qui
donneront une claire orientation d'abord
de la préférence des catalans et puis
ensuite la manière de résoudre dans la
durée cet épisode qui encore une fois ne
remet pas en cause l'unité de l'espagne
et qui ne remet pas non plus en cause la
force de l'europe et la force du
sentiment européen en espagne mais ce
que le président catalan déchu pourrait
demander l'asile à la belgique
il ya eu d'autres fugitifs célèbre
victor hugo enfin à l'époque qui
n'avaient pas encore la libre
circulation des hommes c'est parce
qu'une un asile veut dire dans une
circonstance comme celle ci puisque il a
le droit de en tant que citoyens de
l'union européenne il est comme espagnol
traverser toutes les frontières et ma
connaissance n'est pas encore de mandats
d'arrêt qui est ma course et contre lui
donc
n'évoquons pas le droit d'asile pour une
personnalité qui n'est pas dans une
situation quasi d'accord vous voulez pas
vous immiscer dans les questions de
justice
vous pouvez peut-être parler des
questions espagnol est ce que vous
faites confiance aux catalans lors du
scrutin démocratique est donc convoquée
le mois prochain pour rester dans
l'espagne on peut pas commenté non plus
une élection
pardonnez moi ça craint ça s'appelle la
démocratie et donc les élections les
élections sont une expression forte à la
démocratie ils donneront le résultat
qu'elles donneront mon sentiment c'est
que les catalans dans leur majorité se
chante européen quoi qu'il arrive nous
verrons s'ils se sentent espagnol et
quelle sera la commission à quoi vous
attendez-vous mission tout le monde
certains disent que ça prend là leur
d'une farce aujourd'hui du côté
indépendantistes c'est un peu votre
sentiment à la saison que cette fuite à
bruxelles j'évoquais argos est pas
victor hugo justement et donc je pense
qu'il faut plutôt se reposer sur des
principes solides et ses principes
solides c'est encore une fois le respect
de l'état de droit
le refus de la violence le dialogue la
démocratie et c'est à travers sa grosse
trouver une solution mais je veux
exprimer une manière très claire que la
commission européenne et que l'europe
n'est pas inquiète devant la sphère
catalan cette affaire catalan se réglera
dans le cadre de l'état de droit de leur
quotient l'espagnol et directe de
l'union européenne vous n'êtes pas
inquiet par vous pensez qu'il n'y aura
pas ces sessions donc vous comptez sur
les catalans sur une majorité dans tu en
joues avec un compte sur la sagesse dans
la craie d'alors et des espagnols alors
c'était le semble pour trouver enfin une
solution unitaire européenne c'était le
sujet d'une première question du sondage
exclusif que réalise chaque semaine pour
nous opinionway la déclaration
d'indépendance était d'une menace pour
l'union européenne et bien il y a eu il
y as fait française 56% de nom 42 % 2
oui ils sont sages ils sont sages il
relativise la suite tout à fait de
l'épreuve de vérité avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir jean français ce soir michel
bonsoir pierre bonsoir
alors est-ce que de votre point de vue
de bruxelles de la commission européenne
la france va enfin tenir son engagement
de déficit public à moins de 3% du pib
un engagement qui je le rappelle
d'ailleurs devait être retenu dès 2013
année où vous étiez ministre de
l'économie et des finances
puisque vous souriez je vais sourire
aussi en revenant sur cette année en
pensant à ce que c'est que d'arriver à
bercy quand je suis arrivé à bercy
c'était le 17 mai 2012
les déficits était à 5 2% la croissance
était à 0,3 pour cent une drogue vous le
savez donc à pardonnez moi pour revenir
sous les 3 pour revenir sous 3%
il aurait fallu matraquer les français
n'ont pas avec un choc fiscal magasin
double choc fiscal pour faire deux
points d'ajustement ce qu'aucun état
membre de l'union peine n'a jamais fait
et très logiquement nous avons obtenu un
délai pour le faire taire les deux
années où j'étais à bercy ont été les
deux années où les déficits structurels
se sont réduits le plus aucun de mes
prédécesseurs et aucun de mes
successeurs jusqu'à présent on a fait
cela
aujourd'hui arrive pour nous le maire et
je lui souhaite de passer dessous les
repensant je vais y venir mais il hérite
d'une situation de déficit à 3,2 c'est
quand même plus proche de 3 et d'une
croissance à 1,8 ce qui est quand même
mieux que 0,3 donc je ne dirais pas que
c'est facile mais convenez que c'est
plus facile et que donc votre petite
pique à frapper à côté mais j'en viens
la situation actuelle dans la situation
actuelle
oui je crois et j'espère que la france
passera sous les 3% en 2010 s'est même
fait qu'elle restera sous les 3%
substantiellement en 2018 et que de
cette façon là au printemps 2010 8 la
commission européenne sur ma proposition
puisque c'est dans mon portefeuille sera
capable de proposer que la france sorte
enfin de la procédure de déficit
excessif ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
elle sera avec l'espagne le dernier pays
dans cette procédure il est normal
qu'elles en sortent une france
européenne une france qui a des
ambitions peut être exemplaire chez soi
et donc encore une fois je crois et
j'espère c'est à portée de main c'est
faisable et je crois que le gouvernement
fait ses choix dans cette optique cette
orientation ce que j'approuve est-ce que
vous
vous croyez aux engagements de la france
en matière d'économies budgétaires quand
on voit par exemple dans le projet de
budget 2010 8 il n'y a que 1600 postes
de fonctionnaires en moins alors que le
gouvernement emmanuel macron précisément
s'était engagé sur une baisse de 120
mille fonctionnaires sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat
ça commence pas très bien comme vous le
savez dans le cadre d'un échange que la
commission européenne avec un certain
nombre d'états membres
j'ai écrit avec mon collègue valdis
dombrovskis ce une lettre plusieurs pays
au portugais au belge aux italiens et
aux français pour avoir des précisions
supplémentaires non pas sur les chiffres
dit nominaux c'est à dire est-ce qu'on
est à trois ou un truc 3 mai sur les
chiffres dit structurel lorraine alors
sur le structurel il ya des règles va y
venir être mais c'est lié parce que ce
que mesure le structurel c'est
précisément l'effort qu'on est capable
de faire pour réduire le déficit
indépendamment de la croissance et sa
mesure en particulier l'effort en
matière de dépenses de maîtrise de la
dépense de réforme de l'état de ce point
de vue là les forêts faible il est
faible en 2010 8,01 points de baisse du
déficit structurel 0.2 goethe est
rappelé les règles les règles je suppose
qu'un pays qui se trouvent dans ce qu'on
appelle le bras préventif du pacte c'est
à dire contre 8% ce qui pourrait être la
france qu'a la france en 2010 est doit
faire 0 6 point d'ajustement en 2018
structurel avec la souplesse qu'offre
les règles flexibilité qu'offrent les
règles certains raison critiquer mais
moi je les revendique
on peut faire 0-1 là on est peut-être
entre 0 et 0 1 12 le dialogue on
pourrait être remis en question on peut
faire mieux dit ouvrir 7 me la france
pas va être en dessous tour pression je
ne demanderai pas de manière plus plus
plus de faire me passe gouvernement
français parce qu'on a l'impression et
les allemands d'ailleurs le dise un peu
que vous êtes trop complaisant avec avec
pulp la france à la commission de
bruxelles alors que les allemands veut
ils ont fait ces efforts d'ajustement et
vous vous dites à la france prenez votre
temps pas du tout 3 complaisant
absolument pas nous nous avons la même
règle pour tous nous avons les mêmes
flexibilité pour tous et je rappelle que
nous avons écrit non pas seulement la
france mais à quatre états membres
donc non arrêtons cela il n'y a pas de
privilèges français n'y a jamais eu de
complaisance envers la france jamais
nous avons toujours pris nos décisions
en fonction des règles dans le cadre des
règles je mets au défi quiconque de le
contraire vous savez je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce que vous êtes tennisman deux
peut-être un peu d'accord vous avez une
balle qui sur la ligne aile et compte
est bonne et le problème de la france
depuis des années c'est qu'elle est sur
leur lit elle est ce qu'on appelle dans
toujours borderline 017 admissibles à
condition ensuite d'avoir des efforts
structurels plus important dans les
semaines qui suivent et donc il faut
aussi que la france soit capable d'avoir
cette maîtrise de la dépense dans la
durée donc non il n'y a pas de
complaisance mais il ya aussi une
exigence qui est normal et ce que je
peux dire c'est que la france oui
devrait passer sous 3% mais que la marge
de sécurité n'est pas importante et que
l'écart entre la moyenne des déficits
dans l'union européenne et dans la zone
euro qui devraient être à peine
au-dessus de 1 point cette année 1 et la
france et est quand même très important
et donc il faut à mon sens que la france
dans la durée est à coeur de réduire de
manière importante son déficit nominal
et son déficit structurel et donc ça
passe en effet par une maîtrise de la
dépense publique pour me demander de
passer ce message je le fais je le fais
avec force
elle est pourtant un plus vite dans les
réformes à voir avec une maîtrise
continue et puissante de la dépense
publique pour réduire de manière
effective les déficits structurels comme
domino et et faire en sorte que la
france en matière de déficits rejoignent
le peloton de tête c'est sa place
la france n'a pas être dans le wagon de
queue le panel doit elle est dans les
dryats tendre vers l'équilibré
budgétaire c'est s'inscrivent pas se
contenter d'être juste en dessous de 800
nos règles donc être nos ambitieux
n'aurais-je pas ce que vous voulez de
règle stipule qu' on doit aller vers
l'équilibré bénigne des revers 0 5 point
de pib de déficit je rappelle que la
moyenne dans la zone euro devrait être à
peine supérieur à 1 point en 2018 peut
être inférieure à 1 point en 2019 je
donnerai les prévisions de la commission
jeudi prochain et donc oui il faut que
la france fasse son effort dans la durée
alors vous dis mais là mais j'ai le
sentiment que le gouvernement encore une
fois le cas mais les efforts de sortir
de cette pression du déficit excessif je
l'approuvent et la commission sera ce
rendez-vous d'accord sauf que vous dites
qu'il faut faire des efforts au moment
justement où la situation se complique
sur le chemin des 3% de déficit puisque
l'état français a été contraint de
rembourser 10 milliards d'euros c'est la
fameuse taxe sur les dividendes qui a
été invalidée et la fère a pris encore
ces dernières heures les allures de
règlement politique entre l'actuel
gouvernement et l'ancienne majorité vous
étiez-vous ministre d'économie au moment
de l'instauration de cette taxe à
l'humain écoutez bruno le maire c'était
il ya quelques heures en commission à
l'assemblée nationale
je pense qu'il est légitime de
s'interroger sur le maintien dans le
temps d'une taxe dont le secrétaire
d'état au budget avait lui-même reconnu
qu'elle faisait l'objet d'une mise en
demeure de l'union européenne c'est à
dire d'un ensemble politique dont nous
sommes partie et dont nous devons
respecter les règles quand on perd par
amateurisme une telle quantité d'argent
public
je pense qu'on peut effectivement parler
de scandale d'état
est-ce que vous ne vous sentez pas un
peu penaud parce que ça l'est parce que
vous étiez en poste avec jérôme cahuzac
à l'été 2012 quand vous avez mis en
place cette taxe à 3 % sur les
dividendes dont beaucoup de juristes à
l'époque et dans les années qui nous ont
suivis vous ont mis en garde d'ailleurs
vous ont dit c'est extrêmement frais c
est extrêmement fragile parce que c'est
en contradiction entre autres avec une
directive européenne des young alors
penaud benoît veut nous absolument
serein et pas du tout dans la
problématique du scandale et adhère
j'observe que bruno le maire a un peu
midi dans son vin et vise une période
qui est bien postérieure puisqu'il
évoque t mise en garde qui ne serait
arrivé qu'après 2015
et je rappelle que pour ma part j'ai
quitté le ministère des finances on 2014
mais revenons à ce qui me concerne en
quelle est la situation pardonnez moi là
encore d'être précis pro 2012 le
gouvernement auquel j'appartenais trouve
ces fameux 5 pour cent et quelque peu
public il faut qu'ils réduisent pour le
coup le déficit sans quoi là nous sommes
dans une situation de ce prétendu nous
sommes dans la crise grecque et la
france est proche d'une dégradation de
sa notation
que faisons nous nous compensons eu une
taxe sur les opcvm qui avait été créée
par nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon
et sur laquelle il y avait déjà des
vraies certitudes que la france allait
être aujourd'hui la vente allant de
l'année et donc avant nous venons je
sais par rapport au scandale d'état
franchement cette phrase je la trouve
totalement tort de propos je la trouve
mal venu et je la trouve faut il doit se
sentir visé à l'heure parce que
attendait et j'y viens quand même à
l'époque quand vous êtes mis des
finances c'était mon cas vous consultez
vos services la direction alisation
fiscale sur la proposition que nous
avons faite rien nous consultons la
direction des affaires juridiques rien
le conseil d'état donne son avis sur
l'a9 finances rectificative comme sur
toute loi de finances
rien le conseil constitutionnel n'a pas
validé cette taxe en 2012
rien donc ce à quoi bruno le maire fait
allusion et c'est une reconstitution de
l'histoire c'est à ce qui a pu se passer
appartement où il y a eu la mort cela
revirement de jurisprudence sur la
saisine du juriste qui étaient pour
l'essentiel des juristes patronaux vous
savez que franchement ne voyez pas en
moi dangereux gauchiste à mais si chaque
fois qu'il ya une remarque de juristes
du medef de la fête sur l'imposition des
sociétés
on va s'arrêter il n'y aurait plus
d'impôts de société du tout dans ce pays
il n'aime pas ça c'est ainsi donc non
arrêtons la polémique est malvenue il
faut surtout trouver des solutions moi
je me félicite que le gouvernement est
décidé cela aujourd'hui parce que ça
permet en effet de tenir les 3 % sur le
fond je n'ai pas grand commentaire à
faire sinon qu' il est quand même très
compliqué de parler de choc fiscal
puisque cette taxe elle existe elle a
été payé puisque en vérité c'est
seulement la moitié des 10 milliards qui
sont récupérés ce qui veut dire quand il
ya encore 5 milliards qui sont donnés il
ya seize entreprises qui ont payé des
dividendes qui sont des grosses
entreprises qui ont tout de même et
moyens le faire je ne pleure pas pour ma
part je ne verse pas de larmes de
crocodile et je crois qu'il faut
maintenant avancer trouver des solutions
à la fois française européenne c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire pas la peine
de revenir sur ces polémiques
qui franchement ils sont à force d
instrumentalisation politique de cette
jeune c'est par une pression sur vous
pour que vous soyez peut être indulgent
vis-à-vis de nantes il ya une chose que
je veux dire de surcroît sur la
commission européenne ce a son
importance car c'est plus technique mais
c'est plus décisif c'est que si la
france est sous 3% ce qui devrait être
le cas que minutes surtaxe
exceptionnelle
alors alors en cause des cinq milliards
ne repassera pas autre chose sur les 5
milliards était le sens qu'ils vont être
des lauriers aux entreprises mais simple
que l'état va devoir payer de sa poche
donc est-ce que ça risque pas de creuser
un peu le déficit ce n'est pas mon
sentiment est dès lors que la france
sera sous 3%
l'impact budgétaire qui est créée par
cette affaire sera considérée comme ce
qu'on appelle un one off c'est à dire
n'empêchera pas la france de sortir la
pression de déficit excessif au
printemps ce qui est tout de même
l'objectif essentiel parce que selon
bruno le maire embarrasse emmanuel
macron qui était conseiller de françois
hollande
qu'est-ce qu'il a visé lp de visée par
cette enquête j'ai noté que finalement
et contrairement à ce qui était son
propos est au départ et il ne vise pas
la période 2012 et 14 livres mais il
parle de période ultérieure sur lesquels
par définition je n'ai pas d'information
champagne emmanuel macron non plus
puisqu'il la croiser des gens c'est
françois hollande comme moi en 2014 la
croissance française bons chiffres
publiés ce matin 1 8% de croissance en
2010 est probablement 1,9 pour cent en
2018 ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
n'avait pas atteint ses taux de
croissance est à mettre au crédit de
kiss est à mettre au crédit de françois
hollande de votre votre quinquennat au
fond puisque vous en appliquez paiement
ou à mettre au crédit de ces d'abord à à
mettre au crédit de l'économie française
se mettre au crédit des français des
entreprises françaises
c'est à mettre au crédit je crois aussi
des différents gouvernements qui se sont
succédés pourquoi parce qu'au fond
l'objectif était de restaurer la
compétitivité 16
il ya eu plutôt totale quand même malgré
cette affaire une politique pro
entreprise dans ce pays depuis 2012 et
donc oui depuis 2002 puis 2012 depuis le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi qui
étaient décidées en novembre 2012
le pacte de responsabilité la part de
responsabilité là ensuite systématiser
le cic eux
et la principale mesure pro entreprises
qui étaient prises dans ce quinquennat
cependant quand même 40 milliards
d'euros c'est tout à fait considérable
et donc il ya eu ça donc je dirais pour
françois hollande
pour raisonner dans ces termes là oui
incontestablement
et une amélioration de la croissance il
n'a pas pu en profiter politiquement
mais elle est là et pour le reste je
crois aussi que healy a aujourd'hui un
climat de confiance autour de la france
qu'il ya une image de la france qui est
positive qui a cette volonté européenne
qui est appréhendée de manière positive
qui a un climat à la fois chez les
entreprises et chez les ménages qui est
positif et c'est assurément une bonne
note pour le démarrage du quinquennat il
emmanuel macron donc ne les oppose non
pas en l'occurrence et surtout
réjouissons nous parce que la france qui
on retrouve le peloton tête ont tout cas
qui rend dans le peloton parce que la
zone rouge au delà de 2 % assez
substantiellement
c'est une excellente chose le fait que
les écarts se réduisent que les
divergences se réduisent que la zone
euro convergent
moi je m'en félicite mais attention
quand même quand l'économie va bien
c'est pas le moment de relâcher les
efforts c'est au contraire le moment non
pas de préparer la prochaine crise mais
de la prévenir
notez qu'on est comme dans la cinquième
année de croissance consécutive et que
quand on parle en terme de cycle il faut
aussi se demander à quel moment ça va
s'inverser
moi j'ai le sentiment que sa croissance
et les solides pour un certain temps
mais il faut aussi que les structures
l'économie française soit renforcé et ça
passe par l'investissement qui reste le
point faible de l'équipe française
ça passe par les finances publiques la
réaction de déficit ça passe pour les
déficits structurels parce que qu'est ce
qui se passe quand vos déficits
structurels ne s'améliore pas au moment
où la conjoncture se renverse
ça n'est pas bon voilà pourquoi cette
bonne conjoncture doit être utilisé pour
faire plus de réformes et pour réduire
davantage les déficits nouveau message
du commissaire européen merci merci jean
françaix sa série de l'épreuve de vérité
avec lucile malandain de l' agence
france-presse
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'efs bonsoir
lui si l'on parlait du bon début
économique du quinquennat votre question
sur un autre thème à notre invité par
michel bon sens mais aussi les
gouvernements européens gouvernement de
la zone euro pardon politique migratoire
numérique macron frappe fort avec ses
propositions sur l'europe
pensez vous qu'ils la gardent le
leadership actuellement sur l'europe
moi j'ai toujours été je puisse servat
avec le temps le temps passe je vieillis
donc je suis plus relative ift j'ai
toujours détesté ces problématiques du
style la france est de retour comme
celle avait disparu avant dont la france
existait déjà que nous sommes passés de
l'ombre et la lumière c'était jack lang
qui disait ça au début du quinquennat de
françois mitterrand comme si avant
c'était long mais comme si après cette
lumière les choses sont toujours un peu
plus compliqué donc je ne vais pas dire
quelques semaines à mâcon est le leader
de l'europe
je dirais simplement que et même le
maquereau est un chef d'état français
pro européen qui a mis l'europe au coeur
de sa plateforme électorale et qui la
met au coeur de son programme politique
présidentielle et je m'en réjouis mais
est assurément cette voie là cette voie
française forte elle était attendue et
elle compte mais une voix françaises ça
ne suffit pas l'europe c'est pas la
france en grand il faut aussi qu'il y
ait du répondant il ya du répondant à
bruxelles avec un discours de jean
claude juncker qui a été aussi fort que
le discours d' emmanuel macron à la
sorbonne ce d'un mois parlement en perd
la mi-septembre avec angela merkel
savait l'europe c'est simple il faut
paris bruxelles berlin alignés c'était
mitterrand kohl de l'or quand vous avez
les trois ça va si vous n'avez pas les 3
rien ne peut se faire et donc avoir une
france forte tant mieux mais il faut que
la france on trouve aussi des compromis
des terrains d'entente avec les autres
le françois hollande l'ancien président
vous avez apporté à partenaires de ces
gouvernements lui même avaient mis
l'europe au coeur de son programme
lui-même mettait l'europe au coeur de
ses discours il avait déjà proposé le
gouvernement de la zone euro le 'mes'
des finances le budget de la zone euro
pourquoi est-ce que avec françois
hollande ça ne marche pas alors qu'avec
est manal macron on dit que ça va enfin
marché que ça va enfin je ferai deux
observations une pauvre françois
hollande une pour le maine le maquereau
celle pour françois hollande est le
j'aime beaucoup françois hollande j'ai
été son mini short et directeur de sa
campagne présidentielle et je suis un
social démocrate mais sur l'europe
j'aurais aimé je les dis et je le lui ai
dit qu'il aille plus loin qu'il aille
plus fort qui ne se contente pas de
mentionner ces sujets mais qu'il fasse
un grand discours grand disque aux
entraînements de volonté de propositions
à l'allemagne il ne l'a pas fait avant
de cette façon là assurément emmanuel
macron être un pas devant va plus loin
et je trouve ça très bien que le
président de la république française
soit capable d'avoir cette parole forte
on l'attendait c'est pas le retour de la
france en europe la france est hélas ce
qu'a fait françois hollande sur la grèce
était remarquable mais il fallait un
discours plus systématique remarques
pour emmanuel macron ont plutôt pour
vous par rapport à ce que vous dites d'
emmanuel macron on ne peut pas dire que
ça marche il faut attendre pour
l'instant nous avons les propositions de
manuel mann nous avons la proposition
d'amp longueur et je suis d'accord et
avec emmanuel magnien passe ailleurs et
john kerr il faut un budget de la zone
euro pour réduire les divergences au
sein de la zone euro qu'il faut un
ministre des finances de la zone euro
qui soit aussi commissaire en charge des
affaires économiques
mon post d'aujourd'hui pour animer et
piloter la politique honni de la zone
euro et un contrôle parlementaire
exercée par le parlement européen
mais croyez moi on est encore loin du
bout ça d'abord apprendre d'abord
j'attends que les propositions
françaises soit encore plus forte et
précise mais ça va venir
et puis il faudra aussi voir comment les
autres réagissent à commencer par les
allemands donc ne faisons pas comme si
les carottes étaient cuites mme sylla
bélingard
alors à paris récemment sur la nouvelle
directive européenne sur les
travailleurs détachés alors pour vous on
a parlé beaucoup de la victoire de
macron de macron c'est excessif
emmanuel macron il y est bien sûr pour
quelque chose notamment avec un point
que j'avais salué que je salue à nouveau
c'est le fait d'être s'est rendu en
tournée dans les pays de l'est de
l'europe pourquoi
d'abord parce que la france est trop
absente de cette nouvelle europe qui
nous a rejoint et ensuite parce que il a
eu raison de considérer qu'il ne fallait
pas que ces pays apparaisse comme un
bloc et en l'occurrence il ya même
certains d'entre eux la slovaquie le
tchèque n'ont pas voté comme d'autres
voies laniel en victoire déterminante
monnaie autre texan terrifia derrière ça
il ya une proposition de la commission
et je crois que c'est avant tout une
victoire de l'esprit européen
c'est la commission ces gens qu'une
guerre c'est ma collègue marianne
thyssen qui avait proposé le principe à
travail égal salaire égal
c'est sur la base cette proposition qui
a été faite l'accord qui est positif qui
permet en effet de lutter contre le
dumping social social et c'est une
excellente chose mais là encore vous
savez je suis français je suis en france
il faut qu'en france on perde une
mauvaise habitude de quoi écrire idée
que quand ça ne va pas c'est la faute de
bruxelles
et quand ça marche c'est notre grande
mérite c'est plus compliqué l'europe
n'est pas la france en grand la france
ça marche quand la france prend sa place
au premier rang des nations européennes
s'en tirer la couverture à justement en
france l'opposition par exemple dit que
cette nouvelle ce nouvel accord sur les
travailleurs détachés totalement
insuffisant il a été question de trompe
l'oeil notamment parce que le
comme mondiale le temps moyen de
détachement d'un travailleur et de
quelques mois et que donc réduire à 12
mois finalement ça revient à pas changé
énormément de choses
d'abord la victoire c'est pas dans le
temps de détachement ce sont les règles
c'est le fait qu'on aura effectivement à
partir de maintenant ce principe à
travail égal salaire égal
et quand on dit salaire égal on y inclut
les charges et on considère de surcroît
que le système social qui doit être
prise en compte c'est celui du pays de
destination
en l'occurrence il ya un travailleur
vient dans notre pays c'est le système
français qui n'ont pas le système
d'origine qui peut être socialement plus
défavorable donc je comprends que les
oppositions j'étais dans l'opposition
aussi dans ma vie le juge que ce n'est
pas assez mais je peux vous dire
d'expérience que c'est un excellent
accord sur la proposition de la
commission avec une contribution
française importante et qui représente
le meilleur accord possible
je mets au défi quiconque d'en trouver
un meilleur possible et donc il faut
arrêter de pleurer quand les choses
marchent il faut s'en réjouir
il faut passer approprié il faut prendre
ce clar et puis après ça vaut pour la
majorité comme pour l'opposition
avançons c'est comme ça qu'on montrera
nos concitoyens que l'europe est capable
de les protéger alors justement ceux ci
un stand il ya la deuxième question de
notre sondage opinionway pour l'épreuve
de vérité face à la mondialisation
l'europe est elle un atout et bien les
français à ce sondage ont répondu oui à
65%
non à 33% apparemment en est loin là des
critiques récurrentes sur une europe
naïve dans le monde mais je vous rassure
je me fais une réflexion quand je
regarde 65,33 ça me fait penser à quoi
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle en france
et ça me donne confiance ça donne
confiance dans les français les français
contrairement à des idées reçues sont un
peuple pro européens sont un peuple qui
sait que son avenir que sa place est au
premier rang de l'union européenne que
sortir de l'europe que sortir de l'euro
que d'être dans la critique stérile de
l'europe et de l'euro c'est du temps
perdu alors à côté de ça une exigence et
l'exigence c'est que l'europe protège
davantage puisque même emmanuel macron
me dis qu'il faut la réformer
en pro forma considérable moi je suis je
sais pas je largement d'accord excusable
macron qui lui-même est largement
d'accord avec ce que dit propre le
président la commission
il y a une vision qui est commune celle
d'une europe qui est capable à la fois
de protéger et de promouvoir protéger
c'est la protection sociale c'est
l'accord souliers travolta justement
c'est le contrôle des investissements et
la commission et les propositions le
contrôle des investissements pas
seulement chinois des investissements
stratégiques c'est la négociation de
bons accords commerciaux
c'est la lutte contre le dumping fiscal
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale ça
c'est ma tâche aussi au sein de la
commission
c'est la défense européenne et
promouvoir c'est quoi c'est allé encore
plus loin en termes de croissance et
c'est réduire les divergences et c'est
là où la zone euro a toute son
importance va bien il faut que cette
zone euro soit un moteur économique pour
le question le sel on voit bien que vous
parler d'harmonisation sociale et
fiscale dont on parle depuis vingt ou
trente ans après le terme d'invasion
fiscal par exemple l'idée de l'idée de
manuel macron de commencer par
harmoniser l'impôt sur les sociétés de
choisir les entreprises de les placer
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée et je reprends un peu ce que
dit c'est mon collègue juste avant moi
quand vous étiez à bercy vous aviez
laissé le le taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés très haut par rapport à la
moyenne européenne
est ce que vous regrettez maintenant de
ne pas l'avoir fait baisser j'ai du mal
à rouler en 2012 avec lunettes de 2017
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'on
a complètement perdu de vue la situation
qui était celle de la france à l'époque
aujourd'hui je vois que le gouvernement
actuel fait un peu le procès de
l'héritage du précédent
c'est de bonne guerre on l'avait nous ne
l'avons pas fait suffisamment pour que
franchement non l'héritage en question
mais vous l'avez dit oui mais quand vous
avez cinq de déficit je suis désolé
quand vous êtes obligés de réduire vos
déficits de le faire durement et ça a
été la cause de ce qu'on a appelé le
choc fiscal
elle nous avait dénoncé le premier comme
un ras-le-bol fiscal parce qu'il ne
voulait pas aller plus loin et quant à
l'impôt sur les sociétés je pense donc à
l'étude des principales
nous ne pouvions pas baissé si nous
avions baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés
nous aurions encore perdu des recettes
est encore creusé les déficits
aujourd'hui la situation est meilleure à
corps la croissance est atone on ne peut
faire des réformes en europe que quand
sa propre situation est meilleure mais
il faut vous avez entièrement raison
pour que pour que la france soit forte
en europe
il faut qu'elle soit exemplaire chez
elle il faut qu'elle soit morte chez
elle et c'est la raison pour laquelle
oui j'appelle toujours à les réformer
sur l'harmonisation fiscale
il faut quand même être croit juste sur
les mots il n'y aura pas d'harmonisation
fiscale en europe
tant qu'il n'y aura pas un changement
des règles de décision en matière
fiscale
aujourd'hui toutes règles en matière
fiscale doit être décidée à l'unanimité
à l'unanimité on est toujours bloquée
par le veto de google donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut aller vers
la majorité qualifiée en matière de
décisions que c est ce que peut faire la
france avec l'allemagne par exemple
c'est pas l'harmonisation fiscale
c'est la convergence fiscale et ça c'est
souhaitable même s'il restera toujours
des pays en europe qui ont des taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés plus bas que
nous sommes et l'irlande avec ses 12 5%
justement vont pas que ce soit un modèle
sur lequel il faut s'aligner même si
c'est respectable c'est leur choix vous
avez parlé de françois hollande que vous
aimez bien
il est très présent il n'a pas du tout
de traumatismes après après son départ
de l'elysée manifestement pas de blues
lui et on l'annoncé à bruxelles ce mois
ci pour rencontrer des dirigeants est ce
que vous lui envoyez un avenir dans
l'union un avenir au parti socialiste ou
ce qu'il en reste puisqu'il paraît qu'il
tire les ficelles en coulisses moi j'ai
tendance à penser un peu comme héraclite
qu'il faut pas se baigner deux fois dans
le même fleuve et que le temps pour le
parti socialiste
ça reste mon parti je paye encore ma
cotisation même si je ne peux pas dire
que je suis là militants quotidien ce
parti doit d'être animée par des gens
jeunes qui ont envie de créer un nouvel
avenir qui à mon sens doit être social
démocrate c'est à dire vraiment de
gauche est vraiment européen pour le
social français je crois qu'il ya une
place pour la social-démocratie en
quarts somme toute avec des jeunes donc
oui pas de départ de l'ancien président
mais nous avons fait ça françois
hollande et moi nous appartenons aux
instances du parti socialiste nous avons
un parti nous assurons de mardi sa liste
pendant plus de vingt ans donc c'est à
d'autres de faire
et quant à un président de la république
un ancien président la république comme
françois hollande il sera toujours une
voix écoutée par les français qu'il aime
bien aussi
il sera toujours une voix écoutée par
son camp le camp qui l'a fait gagner
mais quand qui l'a aussi amené la
défaite et je crois qu'il faut qu'il
trouve son rôle et son rôle c'est de
trouver cette voie impartial cette voie
d'intérêt général cette voix forte le
doigt sur les questions internationales
européennes sans doute après midi là
plein de possibilités il est encore
jeune il peut faire plein de choses
il savait choisir selon vous pour
apprendre la suite au ps qui selon vous
pour le plusieurs jeunes qui sont qui
sont bien le droit de donner des noms
exemple jeudi deux jeunes je ne met pas
dedans et je pense qu'il faut surtout
aider les autres encore une fois faut
pas se remettre dans des rôles qu'on a
commis longtemps moi j'ai appartenu aux
instances du parti socialiste pendant 20
ans je suis toujours à socialiste je
n'exclus pas de refaire de la politique
un jour mais je ne le ferai pas comme un
homme d'appareil et il faut que cette
jeunesse s'empare des affaires du parti
et je vais ajouter une deuxième journée
nous quelques noms quand même mais vous
l'avez vous les connaissez non justement
vous dire qu'elle aima martingale à moi
que je leur suggère ils sont plusieurs
et de délais sinon il faut pas envie de
chanter écouter souk dont je lis les
noms
vié fort boris vallot mathias fait que
najat vallaud belkacem johanna rolland
nathalie appéré
vous voilà des caves ou d'un sourire des
jeunes d'accord jean 40 ans ils ont
plein de talent il n'y en a pas un
d'entre eux qui en à l'heure actuelle et
et je crois en situation d'être plus
leader du parti socialiste pour la suite
en tous cas de manière nette et claire
qui ne s'entendent qu'il fasse équipe
qu'ils fassent pas quand il y en ait un
qui dirige le parti pour leur compte à
tous et je crois que ça marchera bien
d'accord ben voilà la loi la main la
leçon à nos impôts mais je n'ai encore
allemand donc l'encouragement le pen
portait lui-même
le français n'est pas à vous demander à
des dons qu'a donc tous divisés puisque
représente toutes les tendances de son
nom voilà tous est erronée il représente
même temps dans d'accord oui bon allez
une dernière question du style votre
propre avenir vous avez dit que vous
n'aviez pas l'intention de prendre votre
retraite politique avant 2019 quand donc
serait plus jamais la recette pas dans
une émission tu en prends pas ma
retraite n'est plus du tout je ne sais
pas j'ai encore deux ans devant moi la
commune est ce que c'est à la france et
à la chose à faire
ministre des finances de la zone euro
coca cola un retour sur ce que j'ai fait
non mais là où l'on se projette là on y
raconte le gong
oui mais je vais vous dire les choses
j'ai toujours été quelqu'un qui a été
animée par trois causes dans le désordre
la france mon pays que j'aime par dessus
tout l'europe parce que je pense que
c'est la place de la france et la gauche
parce que c'est ma conviction et quelle
que soit ma fonction futur ce sera
toujours où confluent de ces trois idées
que s'il vous n'aurez pas plus de
précisions désolé mr ya des choses à
faire c'est vous dire pourquoi je vous
réponds pas c'est parce que j'en sais
rien ah d'accord je suis pas obsédée par
mon avenir je obsédé par ce qu'il faut
faire pour que l'europe avance pour le
moment rare et des finances ça irait
ensuite d'être utile le marlin venue des
finances publiques tout à l'heure le
gouvernement engage la cession de près
de 5% du capital de renault c'est une
c'est une bonne chose
j'ai pas de commentaire on ne
l'encouragé pas éventuellement les
privatisations
mais les cessions d'actifs comme on dit
ou les privatisations
c'est un mouvement qui est continue
encore 30 ans on peut se poser la
question de savoir quelle est la
pertinence
on savait que l'état avait pris plus de
poids dans la régie renault mais qu'il
souhaitait le moment venu revenir en
arrière ça me paraît normal
d'accord
normal alors moi la plus lucide c'est
mais qu'elle aimait ce qui arrive
maintenant pour la dernière partie
[Musique]
enfin michael ho st michel beau sapin
moscovici va parler d'europe mais pas
qu'eux mais commençons par l'europe
quand même après les élections en
allemagne en autriche chez les tchèques
comment faire barrage au populisme
d'abord ce que rappelle ces élections
c'est une chose très importante
on a beaucoup parlé d' emmanuel macron
de l'europe et moi je suis hors
optimiste maintenant je pense qu'on a
une fenêtre d'opportunité pour donner un
nouveau souffle à l'europe qu'on n'a pas
connue depuis 15 ans mais ne faut pas
succomber à l'optimisme béat
le populisme a perdu des batailles il y
en a maintenant perdu la grande bataille
dans un caddie aussi mais il n'est pas
mort et il est au contraire un des maux
qui taraudent nos démocraties avec des
formes différentes il faut pas confondre
tous les populismes
ils n'ont pas le même degré événement
gestion garde composée en allemagne si
vous regardez je peux pas mettre tout le
monde dans le même sac lequel nous fait
le plus peur alors j'allais dire
pardonnez moi aucun et tous je pense
surtout que qu'il faut que ceux qui ont
la démocratie au coeur ceux qui ont les
idées de progrès au coeur est une chose
à éviter est une chose à proposer la
chose à éviter c'est qu'il faut surtout
nous refuser de manière obstinée de
mener des politiques populistes light
pour répondre aux populistes burkina
mais ça peut être des tentations qui
peuvent exister y compris d'ailleurs
dans des partis sociaux démocrates qui
ont parfois été associé à des partis de
droite on prendra tout ça non pas en
france on parle d'europe la griffe dans
les choix auxquels la france et l'europe
mais l'idée qu'il faut être sans arrêt
plus dur qu'il faut faire comme eux tout
en gardant quelques repères de gauche et
pas la bonne idée quand on a des valeurs
qui sont les valeurs des droits de
l'homme et les valeurs de la démocratie
les valeurs de sociétés ouvertes et
valeur d' économie ouverte on les défend
on les assume on est européen
l'idée est un peu protectionnistes un
peu ceux ci un peu cela c'est pas la
bonne idée et puisque vous me parlez de
la france je vais pas mettre la personne
dont je vais parler dans ce sens enfin
quand je vois la manière dont jean luc
mélenchon ne cesse d'attaquer l'europe
je me dis qu'il est à côté de la
ac que ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
prépare à un avenir de gauche à la
france la sphère du drapeau européen
solutions res mais prenons cet exemple
ou immeubles de rapport au ps je n'ai
pas mon passeport sur moi mais c'est un
passeport qui est celui d'un citoyen
français qui est aussi depuis le traité
de maastricht un citoyen de l'union
européenne
nous sommes pour les français des
citoyens français et des citoyens
l'union européenne c'est la règle c'est
les traiter c'est ainsi que nous
définissons pourquoi dès lors
interdiront interdirait ton que le
drapeau l'union européenne soit aux
côtés du drapeau la france puisque c'est
la même chose mais j'en ai dit qu'il ya
une forme de suggestions et au par
exemple aujourd'hui les et demande à la
france il demande à l'allemagne au fmi à
la bce de rembourser 8 milliards d'euros
gagné sur la dette grecque ça qu'est ce
que vous répondez à cela c'est tout ça
n'a pas de sens c'est fou j'ai vu le
bien le gars des profits dénonce ce
matin l'humanité la manière dont jean
luc mélenchon s'est comporté quand il
est allé en grèce il ya quelques jours
pour taper sur alexis tsipras ce qui fut
jadis son idole alors que monsieur
tsipras c est l'homme qui au prix de
réformes difficiles aide la grèce à
sortir enfin du programme dead ça car je
crois que ça devrait se faire à l'été
des mazilles de la gauche et surtout on
a besoin d'une gauche qui soit
européenne et réformistes on n'a pas
besoin d'une gauche qui soit pseudo
révolutionnaires et protectionniste ou
nationalistes non c'est pas ça qu'il
faut mais encore une fois je reviens une
gauche européenne on ressentait un peu
éloigné pour ne pas rayer rendu sur les
8 milliards là de juteux profits sur la
grèce ce pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens et je je reviens
quand même sur le mais ce qu'il fallait
éviter donc ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
ça c'est à dire cette espèce de
confusion nist populisme lights est pas
la solution
ce qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il faut
répondre ou véritable traumatisme à la
peur qui crée le populiste cette peur
c'est une peur économique et c'est une
peur culturel qui est souvent
irrationnels et je pense que la
meilleure façon de faire c'est justement
pour l'europe parce qu'il ya aussi des
réponses nationales d'avoir cette
réponse de protection et de promotion et
surtout surtout il ya une cause qui doit
être celle des européens de la gauche
en france et en europe la réduction des
inégalités
et si en effet certains peuples ou
certaines régions ressentent que l'euro
c'est bon pour les autres mais pas pour
eux à ce moment là se diffuse le
sentiment sécessionnistes où le
sentiment comme nous n'avons pas et donc
il ya la primeur à ça un peu parlé vous
parlez pierre moscovici vous parlez de
valeur je sais très bien que l'empreinte
d'un gracieux le fantasme de
l'immigration il est présent mais
regardez les élections a pu lire ou à
écouter un témoignage juste un vrai
besoin parce que c'est le maire d'un
secteur de budapest on va entendre là
tout de suite lors de reportages de
public sénat elle fait exprimer istvan
bocskai c'est donc le maire d'un secteur
là de la capitale il est membre du parti
de viktor orban année il explique sa
réticence vis-à-vis halle de l'union à
bruxelles est chargée de la répartition
des migrants dans tous les pays d'europe
mais d'un autre côté ils ne
réfléchissent pas aux conséquences de
cela rarement date aucune limite
maximale où cela va-t-il s'arrêter un
million de migrants par année 10
millions en deux ans cinq ans six ans et
qu'elle sera à l' influence quel impact
sur la culture européenne
il n'y a pas de véritable projet le plan
actuel ne se projettent pas dans le
futur ils n'essayent pas d'évaluer le
futur louis david a encore une fois
l'immigration c'est ce qui fait peur
aujourd'hui mon imac discours lahouri de
la fidh est ce discours on soit de
stupidité soit de mauvaise foi je vous
dire pourquoi parce que c'est vrai que
la commission européenne a proposé qu'on
répartisse un certain nombre de migrants
d'asile de réfugiés pour l'essentiel
entre les différents pays de l'union
européenne c'est vrai aussi que ce flux
est en train de se réduire de manière
massive
c'est vrai enfin que c'est l'allemagne
qui en a absorbé la très grande part
parce que c'était l'attrait économique
du chien guerre interne et ça a coûté
chère angela merkel elle était
courageuse je les admire profondément
avoir fait ça mais des pays comme la
hongrie mme konaré plus que cech
c'est à quelques milliers
de réfugiés qu'ils sont appelés à
l'accueil
quelques milliers en république tchèque
j'y reviens c'est encore plus
symptomatique un parti d'extrême droite
qui a fait campagne contre sa capture
plus de 10%
dirigée par un chèque aux japonais et
contre les immigrés savez vous combien
il ya eu de réfugiés accueillis
république tchèque et avec 2600 en
principe mené 12 à l'arrivée 12 et donc
si vous voulez parfois on se dit que
c'est pour ça que par les fantasmes
oui les problèmes d'immigration sont des
problèmes qui doivent être traités au
centre on doit protéger notre frontière
commune mais faire de l'immigré et mon
père quand il est venu en france et est
un réfugié
je sais ce que c'est quand je continue
quand je suis né n'était pas encore de
la suite et françaises ils monnaient de
roumanie faire de l'immigré un bouc
émissaire
ça c'est typiquement ce qui sépare une
peur populaire et l'exploitation par des
populistes d'extrême droite comme c'est
le cas dans beaucoup de pays de l'est de
l'europe
et ce n'est pas ce que nous devons faire
nous devons au contraire avoir une
approche protectrice et généreuse il
faut en même temps vous me paraît devoir
mener en france nous reste deux minutes
quand vous entendez laurent wauquiez
parler de lait des folies de l'europe
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça vous inquiète
est-ce qu'il vous fait peur leur ok
j'avoue qu'il m'avait pas à l'aise le
révoquer un homme qui a hérité d'une
circonscription d'un règne de jacques
barrot août à jeanne parents fervents
européen fervente européen vice
président la commission européenne
inquiète un grand européen et je trouve
que le rock est à oublier ça ces
propositions pour pratiquement sortir la
commission du jeu confère le secrétariat
du conseil des ministres pour des formes
de n'ont pas de protection mais de
protectionnisme ce nationalisme exacerbé
sera menée sans arrêt le pays a ses
racines culturelles sous les atours
d'une chrétienne tous ah non ne me
paraît pas conforme au génie français
après les militants des républicains
choisiront mais je connais cet homme il
est talentueux
assurément intelligent très intelligent
mais sa détermination me paraît parfois
sans limite et quand on touche aux
valeurs on touche aussi à ce qui fait
l'âme française et qu'il a même parlé de
l'âme
certaines de ces propositions touchent
l'âme française abîme l'âme française
merci pierre moscovici merci michael
szames s à la semaine prochaine notre
invité est bien sûr à richard ferrand
très proche du président de la
république il dirige vous savez le
groupe des députés en marche
bonsoir à tout ça très vite
[Musique]
ce